Namo tassa bhagavato harhato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato harhato sambha sambhu dasa Namo tassa bhagavato harhato sambha sambhu dasa
Představujeme svobodnému, noblnému a celkově vysvětlenému.
Na první noc jsme představili techniku, kterou jsme použili a proč jsme použili různé techniky.
Včera bylo vše o hororech při meditaci.
Takže dnes chceme to zbalancovat s věcí meditace.
Takže dnes to chceme vyvážit zázraky meditace.
Budha jim říkal faktory osvícení.
Já jsem slyšel, že se to překládá i jako křídla osvícení.
A on také mluvil o pěti duchovních vlastnostech.
A se pokusím dát dohromady pro vás.
První věc, kterou bych rád, abyste ji porozuměli, obzvláště ti z vás, kteří jste tu poprvé, nemusíte si pamatovat jediné slovo, které vám řeknu.
První věc, kterou bych rád,
Protože Taravada je šťastná a nešťastná ve smyslu, že má mnoho seznamů.
Mnoho seznamů.
Má štěstí, protože vše je pěkně rozděleno do kategorií.
Ale tímto přeměňuje do přílišné logiky.
A vy pak strávíte příliš času, abyste se tomu naučili.
Takže, aby začít na začátku,
tak nemůžeme se ničemu odevzdat bez důvěry.
Důvěra není totéž co víra.
Víra je třeba jako věta já věřím v Boha.
Je to konceptuální.
To je pojmové.
Já nevěřím v Boha.
To je stejně tak špatné.
Důvěra je důvěra v srdce.
Důvěra.
V jednom z písem se mluví o důvěře jako o drahokamu, který očišťuje vodu.
kosmická monáda má sedm drahokamů.
Když armáda přejde přes řeku a voda je zakalená, on dá drahokam do vody a ta voda se vyčistí.
Takže
S důvěrou přichází jasnost.
Důvěra zaprvé závisí na porozumění.
Takže když například poprvé slyšíme učení Budhovo,
Říkáme si, hm, to zní dobře.
A srdce se k tomu začne přibližovat.
Pak si sedneme a začneme nahlížet prospěch vypasánové meditace.
Takže znovu, srdce se přibližová.
Srdce se přibližová.
A srdce je potěšené.
A všechny obavy ohledně života a smrti zmizí.
A konce během jediného sezení.
To tak?
Doufejme.
Důvěra podkopává pochybnosti.
A někdy, i když máme pocit, že tomu rozumíme, tak jaksi zatím není to srdce.
Takže někdy musíme počkat, dokud srdce
než srdce jaksi pomůže nebo podpoří to pochopení.
Někdy srdce cítí, že toto je správné.
I když nerozumíme proč.
A když se nám toto přihodí,
Někdy uděláme takový velký skok té důvěře.
Ať už ten problém té důvěry jakýkoliv nás se to tady netýká.
Protože my všichni praktikujeme.
My už jsme překročili první překážku.
Ale ta pochyba se stane důležitější, když pokročíme na duchovní cestě.
Někdy si myslíme, že nepostupujeme dostatečně rychle.
Někdy se zdá, že věci se zhoršují.
To jsou chvíle pro pochyby.
A někdy musíme znovu si posílit naši víru.
Ať už čtením nebo hovorem s učitelem.
A někdy musíme udělat ten velký skok.
A doufáme na to nejlepší.
A doufat v nejlepší.
A my se toho nebudeme bát.
Pokud budeme rozumět tomu, že v duchovním životě neexistují chyby.
Jsou tam pouze pokusy a omily.
Když děláme něco špatně, tak my jsme se tím něco naučili.
Teď vím, co nedělat.
Takže ta cesta je jasnější.
Takže se nemusíme bát chyb.
A věra je také držená znalostmi.
A znalost má tři úrovně.
Znalost, kterou slyšíme a rozumíme, jako když slyšíme nebo čekáme na dharma,
Jako když čteme knihu nebo posloucháme demotok.
Pak je tu hlubší porozumění, když my sami mluvíme se sebou, sobě.
Když dokážeme vyjádřit dhamu naším vlastním způsobem, tak máme větší intelektuální způsob.
pak to můžeme lépe intelektuálně uchopit.
A to, co se naučíme v praxí, to slouží pouze k tomu, nasměrovat pozornost správným směrem.
Když vytvoříme tento věc jako koncept v naší praxí,
když tuto znalost přineseme jakožto koncept do naší praxe, pak nezískáme duchovní vhled.
Takže v tomto vipassánovém systému používáme v podstatě slovo na zastavení myšlení.
A pak doufám, když se vytváří značka,
A pak snad se zrůstající pozorností můžeme zakoušet věci dokonce i bez zeslov.
A toto je naše inteligence ve svém nejlepším rozvoji.
To je pouze jedna inteligence.
Budu ji nazývat intuitivní inteligencí.
Ty z vás, kteří ví, o co jde, tak já překládám paňa jako intuitivní inteligence.
Ta intuitivní inteligence
Tato intuitivní inteligence se projevuje tělem.
Vidíme to nejlépe vyjádřeno na sportovcích.
Když vidíte tenisty, nejsou mysleli, že ból přijde, musím udělat zpětní smažení.
Oni nemusí přemýšlet, a míček letí, musím do toho praštit backhandem.
Je to čistá intuitivní reakce.
Ale nezapomeňte, že oni nemají tuto dovednost bez tréninku.
Intuitivní inteligence se také projevuje skrze umění.
Když si třeba vezmeme pianistu, on taky neříká, polož prstík sem a tam.
Prostě jenom hraje.
Ale on to nemůže dělat bez cvičení.
pak se také projevuje skrze mysl, filozofii.
A zde mysl se projevuje myšlenku bezprostředně.
A když začneme psát, tak prostě píšeme.
Tak tato inteligence je něčím uvnitř těla, mysli a srdce.
A co my se snažíme udělat, je to vyjmout.
A začít to zakoušet jako čistý zážitek.
Tak toto je proces vypásany.
A ten je jaksi na podstavci, nebo je podpořen důvěrou.
A tomu se také říká zkoumání dámy.
A co vyvažuje tohoto zkoumání je rovnost, vyrovnanost.
Ta vyrovnanost je legrační slovo, používá se sedmi různými způsoby.
Někdy to znamená, že srdce je klidné.
Někdy to znamená, že nevytváříte žádné pojmy.
Ale v naší meditaci je to kvalita totálního otevření přijímání.
schopnost přijmout cokoliv, co přichází.
Ať už to je bolestivé nebo příjemné, na tom nesejde.
Nechte to přijít.
A v této naprosté otevřenosti,
Může tato inteligence pracovat.
A podpořením tohoto průzkumu musí být sklidnění mysli.
A to můžeme nazvat soustředění.
schopnost vydržet se dívat, aniž bychom si furt bloudili kolem.
A podpoření tohoto je správným úsilím.
Když je za hodně úsilí a nejvíc koncentrace,
když je příliš mnoho úsilí a málo soustředění, stane se velmi neklidním.
Když je dobrá koncentrace, ale nedostatek úsilí, usnete.
Ale je to zvláštní spánek.
Je to tento spánek, kde jste stále
Sedíte velmi klidně, velmi zpříjmeně, ale nejste tam.
Odešli jste.
A pak se probudíte a věříte, kde jsem byl.
Je to jako výpadek.
Takže to soustředění a úsilí musí být vyrovnáno.
Když soustředění a úsilí jsou vyrovnáno,
když soustředění a úsilí je v rovnováze, pak to dívání je velmi pevné, netřepe se, nehejbe se.
Nevím, jestli jste někdy pozorovali dravce, když vyhlíží kořist, jako třeba orel.
Ale kdykoliv já se procházím po břeží Jižní Anglie, máme tam takové malé ptáčky, kteří se jmenují tak nějak.
A to se vzduchu stále pověsí.
Nezáleží, kolik vzduchu,
Ať už vítr fouká jak chce.
A jejich hlava je naprosto klidná.
Protože musí oni vidět ty maličký myšky nebo cokoliv.
Oni o tom natočili film.
Ta hlava je naprosto klidná.
Ale křídla se tak jako třepou.
Ale ta hlava je zaměřená na ten bod.
Takže je to stejné jako při naší meditaci.
Ta koncentrační energie je pouze soustředěná na to dívání.
Co se týká srdce, to musí být vytvořeno.
tak to srdce musí být jaksi zúčastněno.
A co to srdce přijmě k té účasti, je zájem.
Když máte zájem, tak to chcete udělat.
A to, co vyvažuje zájem, je takový klid.
Z pohledu toho dívání se je ten klid té vyrovnanosti a to otevření, přijetí.
Z pohledu toho dívání se je ten klid té vyrovnanosti
A z pohledu srdce jde o tu chuť poznat.
Která je vyrovnávaná tím klidem.
Proto já zdůraznuji během dne, abyste při vaší praxi byli klidní.
Nechte být všechny ty představy o tom, něčeho dosáhnout, o nějakém úspěchu.
Dýchejte vzduch a naslouchejte ptákům.
Praktikujte trochu meta.
Abyste rozvinuli schopnost toho klidu a přijímání.
A pak když si sednem, tak probudíme inteligenci.
Probudíme tu chuť poznávat.
Někteří lidé stávají,
Jejteří lidé dávají důraz na to, být soustředěný.
Já si vždycky myslím, že nás to příliš svazuje, stahuje.
Ale jestliže vložíme důraz na zájem, tak si myslím, že nás to příliš svazuje, stahuje.
tak myslím, že poznáte, že soustředění se jaksi vyvstane samo.
Prostě se zeptejte sebe.
Měl jsi kdy problém se soustředěním, když tě něco zajímalo?
Měl jsi někdy problém se soustředěním, když jsi sledoval film?
Já jsem nikdy neměl problém se soustředěním, když jsem sledoval film.
Tak součástí naší praxe je zvýšit zájem.
A pamatujte, že nepřítelem zájmu je nuda.
Takže, když ten zájem má určitý cíl chtít něco, aby se stalo, nebo chtít uspět, tak, když to nejde,
pak samozřejmě, když se to nepodaří, tak jsme zklamaní a znudění.
Takže když cítíte, že toto zklamání vyvolá znudění, tak určitě přejděte na tu znudenost jako na meditační objekt.
Musíte zvýšit váš zájem na té nudě.
Vy prostě sedíte, něco vás zajímá a najednou nuda.
A, to je ta nuda, ta je zajímavá.
Takže teď jsme jaksi mluvili o těch různých vlastnostech, máme tady, mluvili jsme o důběře,
je základem našich akcí.
A to je podporováno porozumění.
A když srdce má toto vědění, toto vědění,
A když srdce má tu důvěru, my začínáme praxi.
A při praxi můžeme zjistit, že občas jsme příliš stažení.
Jestliže toto ucítíte, tak přestaňte.
A přemýšlejte o tom.
Na konci každého sezení vás žádám, abyste sezení reflektovali.
Ale můžete to udělat i při samotném sezení.
A když si řeknete, moje mysl není klidná, není vyrovnaná,
pak byste si měl říct, co bych měl dělat.
Musím proskoumat tenhle důvod toho vzruchu.
Možná je to proto, že se příliš snažím.
Můžu být tam,
Můžu sedět velmi zaujatý a najednou se můžu cítit unavený.
Možná, že to bude jeden z našich starých dobrých přátel, otupělost nebo letargy.
Ale taky to může být, že nedáváme dostatek úsilí.
V tomto případě pozvedneme zájem.
Musíme se naučit, jak se pozbudit.
Nyní, můžete myslit, že to je příliš moc, co musíme vzpomínat.
Možná si teďka řeknete, to je příliš napamatování.
Znamená to, že po každém sezení mám se probírat skrze důvěru a soustředění?
Učení Budhovo to pro nás učinilo velmi jednoduchým.
Co on objevil, byl účinek správného nazírání.
Správné uvědomění je pohled na tři charakteristiky existence.
Pomíjivost,
The fact that everything is arising and passing away.
So I'm interested in the process.
How do things arise and pass away?
The fact of unsatisfactoriness.
So how do I create dissatisfaction in myself?
jak já vytvářím neuspokojivost ve mně.
Mě zajímá ten proces chtění, nechtění.
A nakonec to mnohem jemnější učení o já a nejá.
Někdy, když sedíte a cítíte nějakou emoci, uvědomte si tu vzdálenost mezi tím, který poznává, a tím počitkem.
At least here we begin to see that the body with its sensations is not me, not mine.
The pain in the knee, if I can feel it as pain,
Over there.
Not here, I'm looking, feeling the pain here.
If I can sense the distance, this is a beginning to understand, oh, not me, not mine.
Supposing you're walking down the street and your arm fell off.
A najednou je na zemi.
Víte, já, to nejsem já.
Tady je jasná vzdálenost mezi tím člověkem bez ruky a tou rukou.
Když jsme velmi mali děti,
Řekli mi, že do věku čtyř let se zdá, že žijeme bez jakýchkoliv předmětů, objektů.
Všechno je jenom já.
Pro nás, pro dospělé, je to velmi obtížné si to představit.
Jeden z okamžiků, kdy si to můžete uvědomit, zažít, je, když si přibouchnete prstu ve dveří.
Ten okamžik té bolesti je mě a mě.
Jsem já a mé.
Až potom se podíváme na ten prst a vidíme to jako něco možná trošku odděleného.
A když tak jako vyrůstáme
tak to já, které bylo všude, se najednou stává tam.
Vejdeme třeba do téhle místnosti a nemáme žádný problém.
Víme, že to okno nejsem já.
Ani ta podlaha.
Atmosféra v místnosti nejsem já.
Vše, co jsme udělali, že jsme ten mítřek otočili v ten mějšek.
Tělo je tou budovou.
A mysl je tou atmosférou.
Když jsme v místnosti,
Kdykoliv jsme v situaci, kdy se na něco díváme a cítíme všechny ty rozdílné součásti počitky, emoce a myšlenky tak se od nich vytváříme, vzdalujeme.
tak jenom tenhle proces je poznáváním, že to nejsem já.
A při tomto procesu můžeme jasněji porozumět, co je kvalita poznávání.
Takže...
Tato kvalita poznávání je buddhou nazývána sati.
Uvědomění.
Otevřené uvědomí.
Dívání se.
Vidění.
Já jsem zapomněl sem přinést jeden obrázek, který považuji za úplně dokonalý obrázek Saty.
Já ho přinesu.
My moc nemáme takové ty ekvivalenty na tu postupu.
Máme pozornost, uvědomování,
Tenhle obrázek byl reklamou ve stanici na nádraží.
Já to pak nechám na stole, abyste se na to mohli lépe podívat.
Nevím, jestli to můžete vidět.
Je to výborné?
Tak vidíte tady to tvářička.
Vidíte oči.
Zcela otevřené.
Vidíte ústa.
Zcela otevřená.
Když naši rodiči to vidíme,
Když naši rodiče toto vidí, tak vám dají po hlavech řeknout prober se.
A tím naprosto zničí naší inteligence.
Tento relaxovaný malý čelist říká nám, že nejde o myšlení.
Nám říká, že tam není žádná myšlenka.
Proto v naší meditaci ta čelist by měla být uvolněna.
A co také vidíte, myslím, doufám, tady na tom obrázku, je to čistý podiv nad životem.
když dosáhl osvobození.
Tato kvalita uvědomění je klíčová pro porozumění naší praxi.
A tak bychom vždy měli začít s uvolněním těla, s výšením zájmu a upřením pozornosti na objekt a sledováním.
Když jsem byl v Malajském meditačním centru,
A po meditaci mě někdo umožnil, abych mohl pobívat v takovém malém domečku na plantáži.
Nemůžu si vzpomenout, čeho to byla plantáž.
A blížil se večer, když jsem vzal stav.
tak jsem si vyndal do zahrady stůl, tak jsem z větve pověsil síť proti moskytům, udělal jsem si šálek kávy a seděl jsem a čekal na západ slunce.
Ale on nikdy nepřišel.
Tak si pomalu začal uvědomovat, že jsem se díval východním směrem.
To jsem zklamal.
A každý večer se tam sešly dva psy a honili jeden druhého kolem toho domku.
A ten večer jeden z těch psů přišel dříve a začal naříkat, protože ten druhý pes nepřišel.
A takhle přišel
Nakonečně přišel a když se objevil za rohem, uviděl ten stůl s moskytiérou a ničím uvnitř.
A já vám popíšu, co se stalo.
Postavil se, podíval
Čistá inteligence.
Opravdu mě to vzalo, když jsem viděl u toho psát takovouhle čistou inteligenci.
Takže tato kvalita toho uvědomění je u všech bytostí.
buddhův objev spočíval v této konkrétní kvalitě a jak dosáhnout osvobození.
A to je její široká simplicita.
Je to naprostá jednoduchost toho.
Jediné, co musíme dělat, je sledovat, cítit, zažívat, zakoušet.
Nemusíme o tom přemýšlet.
To stačí, jenom se dívejte.
Tak se pamatujte, když jste zkoušeli,
Takže pamatujte, když jste zmateni, tak si vybavte tuto tvář.
Takže na konci vašeho sezení můžete reflektovat na vaši praxi.
Jak jsem použil techniku?
Bylo to prospěšně, neprospěšně?
Jak jsem reagoval na překážky?
A jak jsem rozvinul faktory osvícení?
Takže tohle nemusíte vytvořit jako eset,
Nesmíte si to vzít jako knihu.
To je prostě jenom na konci sezení.
Prostě jsem si jenom vzpomenul a pořád jsem usínal.
Příště musím stávat rychleji.
To byla velmi dobrá koncentrace.
Jo, to bylo velmi dobré soustředění.
Jak jsem to dokázal?
Příště tohle to musím zopakovat.
Někdy pomáhá sedít ve stejném postoji.
Byl jsem líný v označování?
Takže, OK.
Takže, děkujeme.
Takže, pokud uděláte nějakou meditaci, když jdeme, způsobíme se znovu.